[Musique]
bonjour au look bonjour alors vous êtes
astrophysiciens vous êtes vous enseignez
vous renseigner notamment à
polytechnique à sciences po et vous êtes
dedans alors astrophysicien au cea
saclay et vous êtes plutôt spécialiste
de ce qu'on appelle la topologie c'est à
dire aussi une branche de la cosmologie
qui étudient quelle est la forme qu'elle
pourrait être la forme de l'univers est
il à quelle forme unique
alors non non ne sait pas on prenait pas
certain mais également la question n'est
pas tranchée
alors évidemment quand on parle de forme
de l'univers on a l'impression que c'est
une oxymore que c'est un peu curieux
parce que l'orchestré sud avait
l'habitude dans l'univers c'est
l'ensemble de toutes les choses qui
existent ça c'est l'univers mais
l'univers dans les astrophysiciens
peuvent parler c'est l'ensemble de
toutes les choses avec lesquelles ils
ont pu interagir donc ils ont reçu de la
lumière et cet univers-là s'appelle
l'univers observable lit et peut-être un
sous-ensemble de l'ensemble de toutes
ces choses hiver donc l'univers
s'élançant de toutes les choses
l'univers observable c'est l'ensemble
des choses que les astrophysiciens ont
pu voir avec leurs instruments
essentiellement sous forme de lumière
alors parlé de la force un objet
habituellement on a l'impression qu'il
fallait alex terre de l'objet pour le
pouvoir de l'intérieur je vois la tour
voilà non la forme d'un ballon la reine
une voiture il faut semble-t-il être à
l'extérieur
en fait tu nous as l'ennemi on est à
l'intérieur il n'a aucune chance d'en
sortir parce que l'univers c'est
l'ensemble les choses
il compte bien observable et il est très
grand pour donner une idée le le rayon
l'univers observable ses 46 milliards
d'années lumière
donc on va pas en sortir en disant tiens
on va aller voir ailleurs ce qui se
passe donc pour parler de la forme d'un
espace en mathématiques le grand
physicien le grand mathématicien carlos
rodrigues a finalement montré aux idées
au 19e siècle qu'on pouvait caractériser
la laiterie oui il a fait la cua
l'ariana forme de scop du gauche il ya
des choses qui porte son nom go c'est un
mathématicien extrêmement prolifique et
il a montré que l'on pouvait étudier les
propriétés géométriques et de forme on
appelle topologique d'un espace unique -
en restant à l'intérieur il était
nullement besoin d'en sortir
on pouvait rester à terre et faire des
mesures en faisant des mesures
appropriées
vous pouvez vous rendre compte que votre
espace il est là telle ou telle
propriété géométrie kotoko logique dans
le cas de la terre c'est tout à fait
évident
il n'a pas eu besoin de remonter les
satellites pour réaliser la terre était
ronde et d'avoir de l'extérieur a remis
au mollet on a mis au moment où en fait
on savait dès l'antiquité sous les d
aristote à la ivème siècle avant notre
ère on avait compris que la terre était
ce ferry qu en observant tout simplement
la forme de l'ombre de la terre se
projetant sur la lune pendant les
éclipse totale de lune
cette ombre de toujours ronde est le
seul objet qui éclairée par le soleil ou
éclairés par une source de lumière qui
donne toujours la même on gronde
'cela va faire ça ne l'est que la sphère
et donc on sait depuis très longtemps
que la terre est sphérique
mais on l'a mesuré ensuite toujours dans
l'antiquité la la la circonférence de la
terre a été estimé par eratosthène aussi
bien avant notre ère donc il n'y a pas
besoin de sortir de la terre pour
réaliser qu'elle espérait mêmes mesures
et ses dimensions son rayon et xaviera
et donc c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
avec l'univers où là c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce que dans les cas de la
terre on peut essayer de se déplacer à
sa surface voire way idéal pour eux de
s'en sortir on est dessus et on peut se
déplacer dans l'univers on peut bien se
déplacer dans le système solaire
évidemment mais les distances du système
solaire sauf si petit
au regard de la taille de l'univers que
ce changement de perspective fait n'est
pas un changement de perspective hérisse
à la pause 37 question de faire quelque
chose de très grosse copie non seulement
par les niveaux une idée la distance de
la terre au soleil et ses 150 millions
de kilomètres la lumière la parcourt en
500 selon l'ondh
l'étoile la plus proche la salle lumière
nous ans vient en un peu plus de quatre
ans et demi et la galaxie la plus proche
qui est un ensemble galicienne ensemble
de typiquement de 100 milliards des
toiles la galaxie la plus proche la
grande galaxie d'andromède sa lumière
mais deux millions cinq cent mille
années à nous venir
on connaît dégâts la crise qui met dans
la lumière mais dix milliards d'années à
nous venir
hélas dans l'est lyonnais on les connaît
on lit on en voit certains nous n'ont
peut-être pas tout on en voit certaines
dans la lumière midi milliards d'années
pour nous parvenir et la lumière la plus
lointaine qui nous est parvenue elle a
mis 13 8 milliards pour nous parvenir
d'année et donc ça veut dire que le rsa
d'honneur et ses cinq secondes de john
500 secondes de taille 500 seconde
lumière de taille comparée à des
milliards et des milliards d'années
lumière breake seat
iman microscopiques je vais demander à
quoi ça sert de ressort l'univers
ça sert à faire progresser les
connaissances humaines à comprendre
mieux d'autres mondes c'est comme à quoi
ça sert de connaître la forme de la
terre votre bille heureux des convois
pour faire des routes sur des avions
faire du bateau et en anglais
à noter donc ça peut changer de vue
pratique et puis les routes maritimes ça
dépend évidemment de la forme de
l'albert si vous pensez que la terre est
ronde vous avez une chance en parler
tant de en partant vers l'ouest de de
revenir leur année donc c'est important
pour l'univers c'est important aussi
parce qu'on s'intéresse à la façon dont
il évolue
il est en expansion les objets qui le
constituent comment sont ils formés et
de savoir que il a une géométrie de tel
ou tel type ou qu'il a une topologie trs
qu'il est vraiment infini ou est-ce
qu'au contraire il se referme sur
lui-même
ça c'est important si on veut finalement
affiner notre compréhension univers de
son évolution et peut-être de son
émergence
et donc si l'univers se refermer sur
lui-même ce qui serait une situation
très différente de la situation dise on
t'a donné qu standard on imagine qu'il
est un film est bien finie ça voudrait
dire que nous allons tout droit dans une
direction vous prenez un vaisseau
spatial d'une distance de penser vous
allez tout droit tout droit tout droit
et au bout d'un certain temps très long
parce qu'il est très grand vous avez
fait des revenez sur vos pas comme en
étant à paris vous partez vers l'est en
avion et au bout d'un certain temps et
vous revenez à paris en venant de
l'ouest
mais je vous posais cette question un
peu triviale que l'utilité b parce qu'il
ya une dimension
peut-être quand on voit ça de
l'extérieur évidemment vous cédez
recherche c'est beaucoup de travail ces
débats thématiques c'est de la physique
mais une dimension politique ou fondant
dans la recherche
alors il faut y avoir il sait pas les
parents demandent et la forme de l'hiver
c'est ça la vraie régression mais il ya
des questions qui ont l'air évidemment
un peu curieuse pour le pour la personne
de la rue l'homme où la femme de la rue
elle peut avoir une dimension très
imaginative très presque poétique c'est
pas le quotidien mais ça arrive surtout
en astrophysique oui évidemment on
manipule des échelles de taille des
effets irritants qui sont si grandes par
rapport à nous et celle habituelle
crasto le kilo belle manière
seconde ou la jours ou même l'année
qu'on se retrouve en situation très
curieuse d'autres disciplines sont un
peu dans la même situation
si vous pensez pardon par la
paléontologie au l'archéologie
on retrouve des objets qui ont des
milliers d'années les des squelettes des
fossiles qu'on des centaines d des
centaines de millions d'années et donc
on est notre situation on est dépassé un
peu par les échelles de temps au death
parce qu'on manipule et c'est ça qui
fait qu'on ait finalement obligée un peu
de prendre de temps en temps de la
hauteur pour se pencher sur ce que l'on
est en train de faire réellement et
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train pour
dire des choses un peu vulgairement
paraître un peu de décors et est ce que
ce que nous faisons ça a un sens et
surtout est-ce que c'est pertinent est
ce que est ce que les découvertes qui
sont menées ou les études qui sont
menées peuvent être rendue cohérente
avec cette observation que nous menons
alors effectivement c'est tout une
pratique tout une discipline toute une
ascèse est effectivement l'astrophysique
est capable d'avoir maintenant une
description cohérente du monde tel qu'on
connaît de l'univers tel qu'on le
connaît même si évidemment sa
description va évoluer les visions qu'on
l'avait d'univers ya un siècle et celle
de maintenant évidemment sont très
différentes mais là c'est comme dans
toute discipline scientifique
ça avance au rythme des nouvelles
observations de nouvelles expériences de
nouvelles découvertes et il faut
transformer régulièrement de
représentation pour qu'elle colle au
mieux à ce réel
c'est quelque chose qui vous a toujours
passionné ça que vous étiez enfant et
demi observé
ah oui moi j'ai fait de la trop demi
depuis que j'ai 9 ans et j'ai envie de
j'ai eu envie d'en faire à peu près vers
mi temps j'étais tanné mes parents pour
qui m'achètent une lunette astronomique
la majorité une petite saynète
astronomiques et donc j'ai commencé à
observer le ciel un peu en bricolant
savait pas m'en servir j'ai passé une
semaine à pas réussir en service enfin
bref c'est une histoire assez longue et
peu rigolote
bref voilà j'ai un peu appris tout seul
observer le ciel
donc c'était exactement égale à 10 ans
ça fait
ça fait longtemps plusieurs décennies
que je m'intéresse à la sonic j'observe
le ciel et je m'intéresse à la somalie
est absolument vous avez une autre
passion qui est la science fiction
absolument il ya peu la bd aussi alors
on peu près au même moment alors un peu
plus âgés quand j'étais adolescent enfin
vers 12-13 ans début de l'adolescence
mon père était un grand lecteur de
science fiction donc j'avais plein
d'ouvragés qui sont sous la main et en
fait intéressés déjà par les sciences je
suis tombé sur ces bouquins jia
voilà ça c'est ça qui me plaît c'est ce
genre d'histoire qui me plaît
effectivement dans la science fiction il
ya le mot science trop souvent on
comprend en france et science fiction
comme si on se fie ctive comme deux
sélections s'étaient dégradées des
formes et effectivement les oeuvres de
science-fiction des formes transforme
les éléments cisco technique lisez mal
ici il imagine aussi des choses lors des
fois des choses faut des bons et c'est
pas le point leur but c'est pas faire de
la science fictif comme on le croit trop
souvent c'est de faire de la science
fiction puisque c'est un bouquin anglo
saxons c'est à dire un roman
scientifique une fiction scientifique
raconter une histoire avec des éléments
techniques ou scientifiques
mais pas pour ces éléments la part avec
comme but d'exposer ces éléments la
mêlée comme but de les mettre en scène
et finalement de discuter les rapports
entre les humains et les sciences et les
techniques qu'ils produisent et quelles
conséquences cela sur les humains mais
qui on prend un exemple classique par
exemple avec son regard un peu ce héros
pas comme ça un regard décalé sur des
qualifs sans le report des humains
l'iphone peu inquiet d'ailleurs souvent
voilà la science fiction n'est pas très
comme n'est pas très joyeuse que mon
frère vous passez pas les bisounours en
a décrété un peu de force il apprend par
exemple le
le meilleur des mondes d'aldous huxley
ou ils imaginent qu'on est capable de
faire des manipulations génétiques sur
les embryons humains manipulation
saurait faire maintenant qu'ils sont
interdites pour des raisons d'éthique
mais qu'on ne savait pas faire à
l'époque où le roman a été écrit il est
né si on sait faire ça alors on pourrait
faire différentes différents niveaux
d'humanité les alfa qui vont diriger le
monde très intelligent les bêta qui sont
leurs leur lance mire
et puis les gars mal et delta qui sont
vraiment les égouts d'autres sont les
grouillots et donc créer 4 humanité
finalement on va en faisant des
manipulations génétiques et donc on voit
tout de suite que la question qui se
pose c'est pas tellement de la
faisabilité technique ou de la
possibilité technique de la chose
oxley à vendre ça il se trouve qu
ensuite c'est devenu quelque chose qui
qui a une certaine pertinence dans le
real qui a une certaine cohérence avec
le real actuel
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir
les conséquences sur les humains si on
sait faire ça et c'est présent dès la
proto science fiction avec jules verne
qui avec son sous marin par exemple il
invente pas le sous-marin ça existe déjà
scellé sous marin à pédales grâce et des
gars qui pédalent vraiment littéralement
un peu sous l'eau potable
l'électricité
exo lectrices it existe déjà elle n'est
pas très développée ils ont fait un
sous-marin électrique ça c'est plutôt
malin mais ce n'est pas un effort c'est
pas là où je situerais son effort
d'imagination le plus important c'est
surtout qu'avec ce sous-marin
électriques dont dispose le capitaine
nemo il en tire une conséquence sociale
c'est à dire le capitaine nemo peut
couler impunément les navires anglais
déteste les airs il peut couler
impunément les navires et ils vous
montrent que si vous avez cet engin là
alors vous avalisez être les maîtres du
monde
voilà prête maîtres du monde et comme
disait un auteur de science fiction
américain
c'est pas très difficile d'inventer la
voiture derrière une charrette mécanique
un cheval mécanique avec un cheval mis
dans le double dans le dans la charrette
finalement c'est déjà un effort mais
c'est pas l'effort les plus durs
l'effort le plus dur quand vous avez
pensé à la voiture ou à la charrette
mécanique c'est d'imaginer qu'un jour il
pourrait y avoir des bouchons et c'est
ça qui est intéressant dans la science
fiction c'est effectivement une part
d'imagination techniques qu'ils
inventent des choses parfois ils se
trompent souvent ils se trompent et voir
ils inventent des choses qui sont
simplement plus haut possible
incohérent qu'ils ont avec la fille mais
parfois quand les grappes la science la
relation se rattrape l'association
parfois ils tombent juste mais le plus
intéressant ce sont les questions
sociales qui est donc les pratiques
sociales et le symisa c'est important
pour un scientifique comme vous
l'édition est à faire c'est vrai que
l'astrophysique on semble assez éloigné
de ce genre de questions là de sciences
fondamentales un peu éthérée qui n'a pas
d'application semble-t-il d'application
directe mais en même temps les outils
qu'utilisent les astrophysiciens les
caméras infrarouges par exemple viennent
directement des recherches militaires
quand il fait pour l'électeur infrarouge
pour un citoyen c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir une compréhension
minimum de la science espace de sorte
qu'ils puissent comprendre un peu ses
enjeux exactement où sont les enjeux et
quand on est dans une situation de comme
la nôtre de réchauffement climatique de
comment dire d'un accès moins facile à
une énergie quasi gratuite qui était
essentiellement l'énergie fossile qui
ont eu même est elle même eu des
conséquences sur le climat et sur le
notre environnement
on doit avoir un peu cette conscience
scientifique un soc et les connaissances
scientifiques pour pouvoir jauger au
mieux de ce qu'ils veulent peut-être de
ce que devraient être les bonnes
pratiques dans le futur merci beaucoup
merci à vous
[Musique]